before we start this video we just want
to take a moment to say thank you to
better help for sponsoring this episode
it's so important to take care of your
mental health and for me personally i've
struggled with everything from anxiety
to even depression
i personally sought out better help to
talk about a lot of my issues and the
things i was struggling with before i
started jubilee media so i'm a huge huge
huge proponent of better health they'll
actually assess your needs by asking you
a few questions about yourself
about what you're interested in working
on and then match you with your own
licensed professional therapist and you
can start communicating with them within
48 hours we better help you have access
to over 15
000 licensed counselors from all over
the world so you aren't limited to a
local area and you can find someone that
really suits your needs
they make it really easy and free to
change counselors if necessary
you can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions so you never have to be sitting
in a waiting room or be uncomfortable
it's all done online on the platform
that makes it more affordable than
traditional offline counseling
and financial aid is available too it's
not a crisis line
it's not self-help it is professional
counseling done securely online
and is available to clients worldwide
betterhelp wants you to start living a
happier life today
and of course we have a special offer
for you guys you can get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
jubilee media that's better help
better h-e-l-p and join the over 1
million people taking charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional
thank you again to betterhelp for
sponsoring this episode we hope you
enjoy
the original spider-man were not good
like i grew up watching those and i was
not a huge fan of the top
i look back at my fandom since i was
tiny you know the biggest impact i think
for me has been batman
when people really know comics they know
what you know dc is bringing to the
table
i could see how they can defend like
their video games and their comics but i
don't know how they're gonna back up the
movies no shade but
their movies aren't that great
ultimately you see a very cookie cutter
pattern
of how marvel makes their films versus
dc which is super gritty super dark
i will die on a hill of really
apologizing and loving some of these new
movies more than most people should
i think my only expectation really is to
kind of understand you know where the
other side's coming from how do they
connect with
someone like superman who to me has the
personality of a prick
my name is ryan i'm a philosophy major
at university i studied art
history as well the more i think about
it those things tie in a lot for the
reason why i love
comics so much hey i'm will i'm a
lifelong i would say comic book fan but
but really dc homer as my friend would
call me apologist some would say to a
certain degree
i'm matt and i am as well a dc guy
i'm actually trying to get into voice
acting voiceover like watching all these
animated shows and whatnot it's really
inspiring to see all these
characters come to life through voice
and whatnot so that's what i'm trying to
do
hi i'm sarah marvel's pretty much always
been like my favorite genre of movies i
love watching all the movies
i really love cinematography and i love
how they're always played out so
yeah i'm a marvel fan i'm nick and i
like marvel so much that i bought a 3d
printer and started printing a bunch of
props for it oh
so i've got a four foot stormbreaker
sitting in my room
not doing anything i'm chris i'm a
marvel fan
i wish i could see a super fan just
within the recent years i've been
getting like deep and deeper into it
so there's some things i may not know
about but i'm cold children around the
area so i can get around
marvel is only considered better because
of the movies
walk forward if you agree
unless they're comic book fanatics i
don't hear anybody talking about the
comics letting
the shows even the games or anything i
only hear the movies thank you for being
the only one here
because it is challenging i think right
now to be a dc fan because of that
feeling
socially the conversation is marvel so
extremely that every time dc puts out a
movie it's like almost expected that
you're supposed to on
right because it's not as good they did
it wrong now have they stumbled along
the way
tons of times but i get this feeling
that no one's entering into seeing a dc
movie to just be vulnerable and
experience what they're being given
and that's it's recency bias right
because christopher reed was superman
launched but you also think about the
batman's with michael keaton right and
jack nicholson and and then even batman
forever with val kilmer
maybe not so much after that you know
but there was no marvel movies at the
time
the dark knight kind of faded into into
the background when people talk about dc
movies and it's like those are great
films awesome
i mean we don't have the marvel
cinematic universe in my opinion without
batman begins
all right disagreers come forward
i'm still on your side you guys did you
forget we were here
the movies the tv shows the video games
the comic books the books
when you oversimplify it to one aspect
you're immediately erasing thousands of
people's hard work
and not giving them the credit that they
deserve as they add
to the rest of the brand i guess i'm
thinking could you argue
that simply because of the mcu
more people care it used to be
that to be a nerd back even in the 90s
because i loved spider-man x-men all
that stuff from the 90s
doing cosplay when i was doing cosplay
people yelling at me saying stupid
dressing up in movies all kinds of stuff
now cosplayers get millions of followers
like on instagram the mcu
actually made nerds cool yeah
and so when i think of better i think
like kind of to your point
detracts from all the like suffering of
the nerds who got kicked
and shoved yeah to get here so now that
the mcdonald's exists i'm like oh now
you wanna say that's cool
okay fine yeah i do believe some of the
comics
do better than some of the marvel stuff
that is out like with all the spider-man
the original spider-man were not good
like i grew up watching those and i was
not a huge fan wait the night no no no
no
yeah yeah
he's worse to andrew garfield i see
those movies as like
corny perfection it's like absolutely
cheesy
right i love that he didn't give me that
representation i'm an awkward t
he was like a very just dark and like
brooding like more dc
he just was very not awkward how i
wanted to see
peter parker you're telling me that
spider-man 3 dance wasn't awkward
your generation especially now you can
see that you guys don't really like the
dark greedy because
everyone wants everyone just wants happy
stuff everything's going on right now
you don't want to see even darker i want
depression personified yeah exactly
i think dc kind of shows people like
what they already see in humanity
they're like
wow are cities actually like this like
is this actually happening i feel like
people
kind of get scared and they're like yeah
i don't want to deal with that
our characters are more relatable
let's run real quick it's just the fact
that especially like me growing up that
i could just
look at like these different heroes like
i was like i'm not built like no captain
america but i can relate to him in the
heart it's what matters
and so i'm just like just just seeing
every character i'm like oh look that's
me oh wait
that could be me and i'm just like i've
just experienced that with marvel as i
was like let me just run up in here real
quick peter parker
and his anxiety it's so relatable as a
teenager
and seeing another teenager get all
these superpowers and he's like i'm just
a kid like
me i'm just trying to go to school like
i need a break
it's kind of a combination between the
comics the tv shows the
mcu in total when you humanize a
character first
and then introduce their abilities you
not only
give the audience time to relate to them
and attach themselves to the character
but you give them an opportunity to see
them pre
you know superpower pre you know
amazingness things like that you know
just make marvel just a bit more
relatable to me
welcome welcome thank you
there is an element to dc that i get
that they are unrelatable
superman really is the most obvious
because he's
overpowered from another planet all
these things but at the same time at the
core of all that is this unbreakable
goodness
like superman one of the things i always
found really endearing is he comes from
a different planet he has
unlimited power but at the same time
once he met mom pa
kent you know he fell in love with like
the family and
being a high schooler and learning how
to acclimate and so
at the end of the day they are dealing
with the same human
and basic um problems and conflicts that
we have you know
i think that's where zach really tried
to tie it all in it's with that batman v
superman pc fans
hated they were not about it and just
like don't worry we did too
everyone hated it exactly people were
not a fan of it but it's just like he
tried to humanize these characters and
that's
that's real that was really an important
step to take because
with superman batman they were never
shown to have a breaking point or
be be showed up as the villain yeah but
also going back to representation
relatability like you know
asian not many asian uh superheroes but
you know with shang swing and all these
other characters i would give props to
marvel and as long as it's not forced
you know like shove down that's what i
really don't like but as long as it's
not shoved down people's throats and
like you're gonna have to
digest this yeah and i'm all for it when
you guys did bring up peter parker
and um spider-man's with that me uh
being from new york and so i was just
like
i see him and i see me at the time i was
like oh you know what i want to go to
this college too and i want to go here
in order to do that
and i'm like you know what hopefully
don't get bit by a spot on the way there
so i'm just like okay cool
i genuinely as a kid and like having
what i felt like my own superhero
backstory was like losing a parent
at a young age being kind of a caretaker
to her my mom when i was 15
and still losing that person it rewired
in my brain
many things one of which was take care
of other people and put yourself second
put everybody else first
two never show the crack in that it's
actually crippling you
trying to be perfect because i did
always try to say like
when you see me you're gonna be like how
does he just fly through life you know
what i mean yeah
i thought that was healthy wasn't and
then once i realized that i actually
could be vulnerable i could be
broken and that being broken is more
beautiful and makes you more powerful
that sort of opened up the the
floodgates of
finding those things in the dc
characters and i think the writers
especially now in comics
are going that route my fan community
can be toxic
do you want to talk about a no-brainer
question let's just say i think we can
all agree that
everything right i mean even if
it's something as simple as you know
someone's title changing
or someone becoming a new hero you
immediately
get the people on twitter just being
like i hate this person
i honestly feel really bad for brie
larson because she
got the brunt of it during that whole
captain marvel phase
and personally i liked her i think she's
a great actress i think she's understand
what the problem is
i don't either i'm not a big fan of the
character but i was like this is fun i
don't
know exactly when you dehumanize the
actor
and treat them as their only that right
that that's not being a fan
yeah that's being an ass i remember when
black panther came out a lot of people
refused to see it because they called
they said it's a pc movie
exactly it's like there's so much
vitriol in different corners i like to
believe it's not
most people but like the loudest voices
on social media are like
always oh yeah exactly because those are
the ones that get attention
right yeah even the black panther
anything like this is supposed to be a
black superman coming out and people are
going to be like oh yeah
that's born of the political correctness
but there's there's been iterations of
also it's comic books so why not yeah
it's like it's not only it's only
limited to
just white people and there's a
multiverse for a reason
i get toxicity on my end just for being
a girl and like you guys are
prominent i mean it's all males yeah
but i mean i've never been like directly
targeted at but i definitely do get the
sense of like
oh you're female you don't know what
you're talking about you have no idea oh
you're younger
you have no idea what you're talking
about i really probably could have came
with everybody
[Laughter]
i think the only reason why i didn't was
because it was prefaced by saying my
community
i just i'm not on twitter i'm not on
instagram and so i don't i'm ignorant to
it i guess is what it is
i had a weird situation you know i would
be i guess more in the jock category
growing up in the sense of that was
more my reputation i would suppose but
anyone who knew me and my friends came
over my house like when i started dating
like in high school and then girls came
over my house i had action figures
you know so the jig was up you know like
you know this is really who i am and
what i'm really about and i always found
i got a great reaction from that i think
if people
buy too much into the the toxic nature
of
of marvel vs dc or whatever the movie is
and their gripes on it
they're losing a chance to focus on the
positive of the character
why they love it my side would win in a
fight
i'm walking i'm going for it yeah
oh wow they they know too they know it's
good they know they know what's up
i think that's why the conversation is
is marvel connects more with like
the real person because dc does feel
like titans you know what i mean
yeah and to me comic books are american
mythology i heard that somewhere in a
documentary and it's true you know we
don't have like an american mythos
outside of like
paul bunyan and like some silly stuff
it's superheroes
it's really what it is and superman
batman wonder woman
these like you know atlas holding the
world on their shoulders figures so it's
like it's always them
batman's like plan to defeat everyone is
just i'm batman yeah and everyone on
earth goes
he's right yeah get out of the way yeah
i mean if we're gonna get down to the to
the brass of it
you know pissed off superman good luck
so
someone taking out the big dog you know
i always see these videos on youtube
like oh yeah superman versus hulk
batman versus iron man it's like it's
all made up so people have their own
listen until superman fights goku we
know that's the real
see we're not all delusional
i mean this isn't even a question like
the justice league is way overpowered
like way overpowering right i would just
say their brutality is a lot more severe
compared to marvel characters that was
like the only thing that came to mind i
was
saying mcu is a little bit more light
and fluffy so they have a little bit
more humanistic
like thoughts um and i just feel like
they would completely just destroy
them unfortunately i guess my only
question would be you know
if you want to pit one person against
another person you know
the whole argument that i hear a lot
with you know dc fans is batman with
prep time with baptism
what is that argument because he's just
a dude
i've never made that argument because
honestly the argument is usually he's
already had the prep time
okay that's always the twist is that you
just assume he's already figured it out
batman's prepared for every pot like
his mind is like i've calculated 17
million outcomes
like if he thought to strange
essentially yeah like if they were
together in a movie doctor strange was
like i saw these outcomes he'd be like
yeah i did too yeah
and as a reader too not just a viewer i
do get bored of that you know what i
mean
because then there's almost no stakes
it's like batman knew all along i was
like oh cool so it wasn't even
it didn't even matter you know what i
liked about infinity war
and the snyder cut was the level of
dread you felt for the characters and
what they were having to go through in
order to get to their goal
and their goal was not ultimately met
especially with infinite i got
so emotional at infinity war and my head
literally hurt after watching that
like a lot having the character
characters be vulnerable yeah like not
having them
at their peak is very important for
the audience to be able to relate and to
be able to feel for the characters right
martin scorsese said marvel movies are
not
cinema step forward if you agree
now step forward if you disagree
well what does he know about making
movies right
i think we all are going to disagree
pretty heavy with that one if you look
at
not just the numbers and not just the
worldwide success but also the stories
and the emotions
and the ebb and flow of of the
storytelling i think they're definitely
not only cinematic but some of the best
examples
of art that a worldwide audience of
different ages
a lot of different people can come
together and watch and enjoy
you know or maybe sometimes a more
boutique or arty film
might not have that same you know
response yeah i think the second you try
to put ground rules on what art
is you fundamentally don't understand
you're missing the point of art
absolutely for sure like how do you
define cinema right you can't
right there's no you know cookie cutter
definition of oh okay this movie is
cinema but like shrek 2 is not like
it's high cinema but it's it's that type
of thing where if you decide
that things have limits you're already
not only limiting the audience but
you're limiting creative freedom you
know if someone comes along and says oh
that's not cinema
what are you telling the future
filmmakers that what they want to do is
not considered cinema you're immediately
you know trashing what these new people
want to do
it brings people together is the biggest
thing i think a cinema can do that yeah
i mean me and my dad watch it together
me my mom me and my friends and we're
all different ages
that's like the point of cinema mm-hmm
that was fun good conversation good job
boys
[Music]